a new report from the CDC shows that the
smoking rate among adults was sixteen
point eight percent last year down from
20 point nine percent in 2005 this is
about a twenty percent decrease over a
nine-year period this is the lowest ever
recorded smoking rate since the Center
for Disease Control and Prevention
started tracking cigarette smoking rates
people who do smoke are also smoking
less the average number of cigarettes
smoked daily dropped from 16.7 in 2005
to 13.8 in 2014 so those who are smoking
or smoking for your cigarettes which
groups saw the most significant
decreases in smoking rates well maybe
not surprisingly adults 18 to 24 saw the
largest decrease in cigarette
consumption uh up number of reasons for
this many campuses have banned all forms
of tobacco when you have fewer parents
smoking you are going to have fewer
children smoking that also follows
logically why else does the CDC think
this is happening anti-smoking media
campaigns new laws and accessible
quitting smoking solutions and partially
it is because of some of the new
alternatives to smoking methods
e-cigarettes for example did not count
as smoking cigarettes in this study so
to some extent that that is also a
factor who is having the hardest time
quitting smoking the poor including
those on Medicaid they have a smoking
rate that is almost seventy-five percent
higher than the national average and if
you look at those earning nineteen
thousand seven hundred ninety dollars
the federal poverty level over a quarter
smoke which is about fifty five percent
higher than the national average there
have been some thoughts Louis of banning
smoking at all public housing in various
states it would definitely have an
impact it would definitely target one of
the groups that smokes the most and can
also least afford to waste money on
cigarettes but is that a nanny state is
that similar to saying hey food stamps
you can't get crab you can't get fish
you shouldn't be buying condiments etc
etc where is the line
um yeah you tell me as ask your local
representative I don't know but uh of
course when I've said this before when I
was in Texas I worked on sixth Street uh
big big big big homeless population over
there yep and i do not think i met one
that did not smoke interesting uh now
they may not have been buying their own
cigarettes no no very very rarely yeah
uh it's I I do wonder if this is just
gonna be a thing of the past I mean in
10 years in 15 20 25 years will smoking
cigarettes be a thing of the past it's
certainly less prevalent in the US than
it is in many other countries Eastern
Europe smokes a lot whenever I go to
Argentina it still seems like the
smoking rate there is higher although I
don't know specifically what it is it
would be great to think that this could
just be completely eliminated uh yes and
it's uh I think it could happen here
definitely but um in other parts of the
world Eastern Europe I mean even Western
Europe Israel uh so much cigarette
smoking and these companies these big
companies are targeting children in so
many countries uh you know in in Asia
but that crazy Dave it's crazy that this
stuff exists this day and age during
tomorrow's audience questions we're
going to discuss a question about
whether you could you could uh be with
someone who has very different political
religious views than you could you be
Louis with someone who smoke cigarettes
uh well I have and it's not easy uh and
maybe that's part of the reason why it
didn't work out but we you think that uh
well I mean someone who smoke cigarettes
just has a completely different take on
on life and the world than me I mean to
hell right so it's not necessarily just
because of the cigarette smoking itself
but you're saying someone who regularly
smoke cigarettes may have other areas of
of of a lack of shared values or
priorities is it whether it comes to
health or whatever else I think so yeah
it's a completely different state of
mind fascinating fascinating alright
let's take a break that's tomorrow on
audience questions we still have more to
discuss today including a supposed
picture
of the type of bomb that may have
allegedly possibly taken down that
Russian metrojet plane that's after the
break